in just a moment one of those senators
ted cruz will join us with reaction but
first here are some of the well not so
kind words from chuck schumer about
senator cruz's home state of texas take
a look
the bottom line is texas thought it
could go at it alone
and built a system that ignored climate
change it was not what's called
resilient
and now texas is paying the price i hope
they learn the lesson when we build
power
when we build anything now we have to
take into account that climate change is
real
or people will be caught the way the
people in texas were
that's exactly the wrong analysis here
with reaction texas senator ted cruz
senator texas rightly and i would highly
recommend you stay this way
stayed away from federal uh
federal bureaucracy as it relates to
your power grid and i would
advise strongly you continue to stay
that way that's not what the problem
really was is it
well that that's exactly right chuck
schumer there was engaged in
all politics and and not focused on
facts or reality
the facts a reality uh are that texas
has some of the lowest energy prices in
the country
the cost of living is affordable there's
a reason people are fleeing the state of
new york there's a reason people are
fleeing
the state of california because the cost
of living is so high
that working men and women can't afford
to be there whereas in texas the cost of
living is much much lower
now we just came off of a very difficult
week
where the grid failed four million
texans and so we need to have a serious
examination
about why that was why the grid came
short
but one of the major elements of that is
actually the policy that schumer is
pushing for the whole country
which is the green new deal you look at
texas right now about 25 percent
of our electricity capacity is wind and
yet
in the middle of this storm that
capacity dropped
all the way down to two percent you want
to talk about reliability
the the reality was in the cold the wind
turbines froze
and and the power generation wasn't
there that needs to be fixed and by the
way that's the solution schumer is
trying to force on the whole country
and right now the democrats want to
federalize
power in the state of texas we need to
make sure this never happens again that
you don't have 4 million people
losing their power and i got to say
texans are
are ticked off that the energy capital
of the world that our grid
didn't meet the energy needs of our
state and i'm confident texas is going
to make sure
that doesn't happen again not by
doubling the cost of people's
electricity bills
but by making the grid more reliable and
more resilient
as i went through the litany of the the
nominations now and
garland didn't seem to know much of
anything
you look at tandem you look at some of
these other appointees
have you decided where you're going to
vote and what stood out today
in particular about garland well
garland has a good reputation as a judge
he has a reputation for integrity he has
a reputation of being relatively
nonpartisan as a judge
i i will say the hearing was frustrating
as it went on today because he basically
dodged every question he refused to
answer
he answered like a judicial nominee and
not like a nominee to be attorney
general so he wouldn't answer
whether he would fire durham he wouldn't
make any commitment at all you know bill
barr when he was being confirmed
he said he would only fire bob mueller
for good cause
i i asked judge garland will you make
the same promise about durham and he
just said
well i don't know anything about it he
was also asked
will the department of justice continue
to process
people illegally crossing the border he
wouldn't make that commitment he said i
don't know i asked him will the
department of justice seek to overturn
the heller decision
and essentially repeal the second
amendment right to keep and bear
arms again he said well i can't make any
commitment on that
i it it was a really disappointing
performance in total because he wouldn't
be candid he wouldn't be forthcoming and
you know you were talking about extreme
nominees javier bacera
is an example of that the biden
administration likes to talk about their
science based
and and their priority is stopping kovid
well javier becerra has been nominated
to be the secretary of health and human
services
he's not a doctor he has no scientific
background he has no background in
virology
he's never worked in a pharmaceutical
company he's got nothing to do
with health care but what is he he's a
trial lawyer
and and his only experience as far as i
can tell with health care is he sued the
little sisters of the poor
and if a republican nominated a trial
lawyer
to lead the health and human services
department
in the midst of a global pandemic they'd
be
laughing out of the room because it
would be absurd
and yet the biden administration's focus
is on
paying off the liberal special interest
not on
being based on the science and defeating
the pandemic you dropped off
your daughters in mexico you came home
in a day
probably less than a day and here you
have this scandal with governor cuomo
barely mentioned on these so-called
other news networks
you're like 24 7 because you dropped
somebody off and you came back home
i still think you can be a father and
senator at the same time
and then you look at the scandal in new
york and the cover-up
uh where's the proportionality from the
mob in the media we got less than a
minute
well you're right and i think the media
is suffering from trump withdrawal
where they've attacked trump every day
for four years they don't know what to
do so
so they obsessed over my taking my girls
to the beach
i got to tell you today i asked merrick
garland if he would open an
investigation into andrew cuomo's
shameful policies a senior cuomo aide
admitted they lied
they covered up the policies that sent
covet positive people into nursing homes
and may well have resulted the deaths of
thousands or tens of thousands
merrick garland wouldn't commit to
investigate it and the media won't even
cover it
and they did it to avoid a justice
department investigation
i there was a name for that when i grew
up i think you know what it's called all
right
senator thank you